[Music]
hello everyone
in this episode i will tell you how i
built an online bookstore
using aws stripe and react
from aws i use aws amplify library to
connect resources at
aws end so we are going to create an
appsync api
as our graphql api and then we will
create
s3 buckets to store our book images and
so on
now before i start i want to tell that
i'm not going to cover each and every
line of the react code
what i will be covering is how to
connect to aws
from react i will also be covering
different relationships
like many-to-many relationship between
books and orders
and also different authorization
mechanisms for example
the admin users can create books but
unauthenticated like the guest users
can only view the books if they want to
check out they have to login but still
again they are not able to create books
that's only for the admins
and finally i will tell you how i did
the checkout part as well
including the payment processing order
creation etc
you will also learn how i use pipeline
resolvers
to deal with different custom logics and
then
create resources or create records in
dynamodb table
from within lambda functions well i'm
really excited about this project so
without further ado
let's look at the learnings and the
agenda that we are going to cover in
this video
and hey if you are interested about this
content make sure you subscribe to my
channel for more videos just like this
so let's start with the product demo so
i'll go through all the pages
and the main functionalities and then
let's look at the architecture diagram
and it will contain what resources are
we using and how they connect each other
and then let's start configuring our
application cloning the github
repository
of course i'll put all the code in the
tab repository so you guys can look at
the front-end code
and then we will initialize an amplify
project into the react application
then we are going to add multiple
amplify categories
starting from the authentication which
will handle all the login sign up all
that part
and then the storage category where i
will create an s3 bucket
to store images and we will also use
function category to create two lambda
functions for
pipeline resolvers to handle the
checkout functionality
then we will also be adding the api
category
and we'll specifically add a graphql api
so our front-end can communicate with
the dynamodb tables and so on
and then i'll explain the process of
processing orders
and once all these resources are synced
with the cloud
then we'll look at how we can
communicate with them or interact with
them from within our front-end react
application
then we'll see how we can verify a order
that is placed by the customer
from the stripe dashboard as well as
from appsync
console and finally we will be deploying
our application to s3 as an static
website
now let's have a look at the final
product demo
okay now this is our online bookstore
it's called wisdomly
and it has multiple menu point home
books cart and checkout
so in the home page we can either view
all books or
see the featured collection right here
so if i open up one of these
books let's say the details section it
will show the title description the
author and the price
and also i can add it to the cart and if
i go to the book section
then it will show all the books that i
have including featured and unfeatured
ones
and then i have the cart so at the
moment okay there's a
one thing let me take it out so it's an
empty cart right here
and then we have the checkout page so
checkout page
is not loaded unless you sign into the
application
and we have a hidden link as well so
that is for admin
so you can go to slash admin and then
you will be directed to another sign-in
page so here
we can login as an admin and start
adding new books to our store
so this is basically that mean section
let me sign in okay
so i can like choose a new book
let's say this one again i can
type the title and the description
let's add a new description and the
author
napoleon hill and the price it says 35
then we can select whether this is a
featured book or not let's say no
and we can submit it well i haven't
cleared the input but
anyways it will be submitted
let me sign out and go to home
or the books and then do a refresh then
i should see the
new book right here now let's add
something to our cart
so i'll come here and then i'll add this
book and i can increase the number of
books i want to add you can see the
total get updated
accordingly let me add another one let's
see this one
to make habits okay added and another
one maybe
okay 100 startup okay
so now i can check out so if i click
checkout then i have to login
so let me log in with the user
so if you haven't sign up you can click
create account and sign up
and then i will sign in
then i get to the checkout page i can
put
the address and then the card number so
right now we have linked the stripe test
account so the default
card number is 424242
28 and the csv one one one
and one two one two okay something like
that
and i'll take a console so you can see
the console message
i click submit payment there you go
all day is successful so now i can go to
the stripe
account and see if i get a payment
and here we go we just got a payment
now let's look at the architecture
diagram now it is not a very complex
architecture that we have
we'll be using most of the serverless
services
now starting from the front end of our
bookstore
we'll be coding it in react library
and the final application we will be
hosting it on s3 bucket
which has static hosting enabled then we
also have another s3 bucket
to store all the public images now these
images can be accessed by anybody
authenticated or guest users now in the
react front end
we have the amplify library installed
now we use amplify library to connect
with our backend
so as our backend we have an graphql api
which is powered by appsync and that is
going to handle crud operations for
books
such as admin create books user read
books
etc now all this crud operation will be
handled by
vtl templates or velocity templates
and the best part is we never have to
write any of these templates because
that is automatically being provided by
amplify when we are configuring this api
and not only the vtl template it will
also provide all the queries mutations
and all these
front-end resources to connect with our
backend without we having to write
any of those codes and then we have
the amazon cognito as our main
authentication provider
but in this application we will also be
using multi-oauth
functionality which we will use both
amazon cognito
as well as identity and access
management or iam
to allow guest users to connect to our
backend
and read the books and then we have the
pipeline resolver
that is built to process the payments or
the checkout process
so as soon as a user checks out then
the first lambda function get triggered
to make the payment will
charge the customer and before charging
the customer it will acquire user
details from cognito and then only it
will charge the customer with
more user details and after the charging
is successful
then the next lambda function takes over
and create the
order in dynamodb table so this is the
serverless architecture that we'll be
using to create our bookstore
all right so now to start let's first
clone our repository
so i'll head over to the github
repository i'll put the link below and
then click
code and get the clone url
i'll make a new directory
my bookstore and then do budget clone
to that directory
cd into that and open it in visual
studio code
so in the folder structure source folder
contain all the source code
and then we have a video resources
section and it has different code
snippets and other resources which i
will use during this video
next let's initialize an amplifier
project in aws and connect our project
now we need to install amplify cli so
make sure you install this exact version
to avoid
any conflicts due to library updates
npm i-g at aws amplify cli
at 4.24
so this will install amplify cli
globally
now before initializing an amplify
project we have to configure amplify cli
with your aws account
so let's type amplify configure
then you need to sign into your aws
account and after
that you can hit enter then you have to
pick which region you want to spin up
all the resources i will choose
usd2 and amplify username
let me type amplify manage
click next permission administrator
access is by default selected
review and create user
hit enter again you have to add the
access key
and secret access key i'll add the
access key here
and i'll add the secret access key of
the camera
okay hit enter then you can
provide a profile name i type youtube
profile so that setup a new user now i
will type amplify init
to initialize an amplifier project on
aws
enter a project name my bookstore sound
good
i'll let the environment name as prod
let's develop for production directly
and then visual studio code javascript
react
source distribution is on built
accept all the defaults now pick the
youtube profile
as my aws profile
with that we have successfully connected
our application to an amplifier project
next let's add authentication with aws
cognito
type amplify add auth
and accept the default configuration the
defaults are good for application
select username for sign in now i am
done
with that it will configure a user pool
for our application so that our users
can log into it
now as the next configuration let's
create an s3 bucket to store
images for our books type amplify
add storage select contain images audio
etc let's provide a friendly name for
this category
book images bucket name i'll accept the
default because this has to be unique
who has access to it both oauth and
guest users as you have already seen in
the demo
even a user who has not logged in should
be able to weave the books
so let's pick the option both
authenticated users and guest users
hit enter now for authenticated user
he should be able to create read
and delete now if you remember the admin
user who logged in he can create books
but the other users who logged in cannot
create book
we will accomplish that by adding this
admin user to an admin group
hit enter then what kind of access a
guest user has
only the read access is necessary
because he should be able to
view the books hit enter
no lambda triggers with that we have
configured the s3 bucket successfully
with our application
next let's add two lambda functions to
process
a book code now when a user add the
required books to the cart and then
press checkout
we have to do two things number one we
will charge the user
using stripe and number two we will
create the order
and then we will link the order with the
books that he requested
to handle these two activities we'll use
pipeline resolvers in
appsync more on that later type amplify
at function select lambda function
a friendly name for this category let's
call it
this our first function that will charge
the user
so we'll call it process payment
hit enter i'll accept the same name for
the lambda function
and then i'll choose node.js as the
runtime for this function
hit enter i'll use the hello world
template
no and i don't want any
recurring schedules no lambda layers for
now
i will update the lambda function little
later so i'll hit now again
then let's add our next lambda function
amplify add
function again lambda function friendly
name
let's say create
order create order will accept as the
same name for the lambda function
runtime node.js hello world no no
no no again now as we're adding this
resources you can see there's a folder
automatically created called amplify
and under that you will see there's a
folder called backend
so in that backend right now we have
three folders
one for oauth the oath category we
configured
the storage category we configured and
the functions
now here are the two folders for two
functions that we created
create order and process payment okay as
the next step
let's create a graphql api so that our
front end
the react application can communicate
with appsync
amplify add api hit enter
select graphql mybookstore is fine for
the api name
the default authorization type i will
choose cognito user pool
however we will be using multi-auth so
that we can use
cognito user pool to authenticate our
logged in users
and then api keys to authenticate our
guest users so let's first select
cognito user pool and the next questions
don't click
no i am done or don't select that rather
select i want to make some additional
changes
hit enter then the next question asks do
you want to configure
additional types type yes
hit enter then select api key with your
space
bar and hit enter then description for
the api key
guest user access to
books you can type anything hit enter
how long is it going to be valid the
apik i'll put
the maximum 365 days no conflict
detection
i don't have actually i have but let's
copy paste later let's choose single
object
as the example do i want to edit it
this time let's edit it right away i
will go to my video resources
and then i should see the schema.graphql
i'll copy the whole thing
and come back here delete this and paste
it
now this is the schema for our graphql
api that choose aws appsync
now we have multiple types as you can
see we have book type
book code type again an order type
and also the mutation types
and these rest are input types so let's
look at the first type
the book code now our whole application
is revolve around
books right so for a book let's add an
id
field and it has a title description
image url the author whether or not it
is featured
so that's the flag boolean flag and then
the price
i'll get to the connection in a bit so
but these are
the main attributes for a book and here
i'm using the oauth directive of amplify
and i have multiple rules configured the
first rule states
allow the group admins so allow all the
users in this
group to create update delete
and do all these things because admins
should be able to do any of that
so that's why when i log in with an
admin user i could
add and book but if i'm not part of the
admin group
even though i signed in i cannot do that
now this is handled through cognito user
pool authentication
then we have two other rules one of that
is private and operation
is the read so this means all
authenticated users can read the post so
both authenticated users and guest users
should be able to read the
post so that's what i added two rules
allow private as well as allow public so
public as
in the guest users who are not
authenticated and we allow them to
read so that they can see all the books
so people
in the admin group can do whatever but
the others
who authenticated or the guest users can
only read
the books then i'm using another
directive called model
so this directive is going to create a
dynamodb table
for this type so for this book type
it's going to create a table and also
and also
it will create the vtl template so
velocity templates that will handle
create read delete and all this crud
operation
and i pass an attribute or a parameter
called subscription
null so this means it is not going to
create any subscriptions
but it will create the mutations and the
query so the mutations we can create
update
and with queries we can query the books
so we don't need real-time updates so
that's why i set subscriptions to now
now let's look at our next main type
that is
the order for an order it has an id
field
and then it has the user the username
who made that order and the date of uh
order
the total load so that is a float and
then we have a connection
we'll get to that in a bit so then i'll
use three directives here
number one the model again it is going
to create a dynamodb
table folder just like books and create
all the crud operation for that
and then we have oauth and i have two
rules
one of the rules is allow the users
in the group admin to do anything so
they can view they can
delete read update orders from the users
so
there's no restriction for admin users
then there's another rule
it says allow the owner that means if
there's a user who logged into the
application it could be an admin or he
could be a normal user
he can see the orders that he created
but he cannot see the orders that is
created by other users
now both of these rules are handled by
cognito user pool
and when a user logged into the
application using cognito usable there's
an email
field so i'm using that email field
as the identity field for order
now when we have email as the identity
field we can easily allow
our backend functions to create an order
for a particular users
because as you know before we create an
order we have to do
a set of things we have to charge him
and we have to see whether it is
successful or not
and then only we will create the order
for him
so to handle all that complexities we
use those two lambda functions
and towards the end we will create the
order for the user by using
dynamodb sd case that's where this email
fields come
handy next we have a at key attribute
so this is we define a secondary index
and the index name is by user and we use
the user field
here i'm planning to add the username so
the admins
can query users by their username not
only just by using the table primary
keys which obviously
the id so we have more flexibility to
query with this
secondary index and they can in fact
type queries
find all the orders of the user whose
username starts with
let's say manoj next we have the
mutation called type now this
is the default mutation and when amplify
converts these
types to the full-blown scheme right
anyway it's going to create the
mutations for
older books and all that but now we have
a custom need
that is we have to create a new mutation
for processing orders and it is not
directly linked with a
dynamodb table also but we have to run
two functions so it's a custom name so
that's why i'm creating the mutation
separately for that
so i call it process order and it will
take the
input as the process order input now it
is this one
now when a user clicks checkout we will
get
the full array of his cart items
and then the total and the token from
stripe
and the address so we get this as the
input
and then we will output at the end
the order status whether it is succeed
or failed
now as this data comes in it will
execute
two functions sequentially and we call
it a pipeline resolver
so in our pipeline the first function
that get called is the process payment
the function we created earlier and then
we have the other function
so this will make sure the stripe
payment is successful if and only if
call this create order so let's add code
for these
two lambda functions i'll go to
video resources and then i should see
the process payment js
let me copy this whole thing close this
and in the back end i will go to the
functions
process payment and then source folder
index
you have a simple handler function let
me delete that and
paste that code the process payment
function is very simple
if i go to the handler function it will
do two things so it will first get the
total price for the order
from the input that is passed to this
and then it will charge the customer
so from the event we can get the
arguments and these
fields are extracted from that and out
of that there's this total
then i'll use stripe sdk to charge the
user
the amount the total amount in usd
currency
then the token of stripe that is being
passed down to this one and then as
description let's say order the date and
the email
now there's a one small thing guys we
have to get the user's email using
cognito
admin api so that's what this function
does
so if i go to this function user email
so this is that function we will call
the admin get user function with the
parameters the user pool id
and the username because the username is
passed down to us as the claim but we
don't get the email
as the claim so in order to get the full
user context we have to
call this admin get user with these
params
of course and then i'll return the email
and this email is here then
i'll add that as the description here i
can add the username as well let me in
fact do that
username with
email so that's about process payment
function
let's go to our video resources and go
to
create order function and then copy the
whole thing
so on the function let's expand the
create order source
index.js delete this and
paste so the process order does few
things
now the earlier function and this get
called sequentially so we can pass
down some information from the previous
function to this
so i will get the order details from the
process payment lambda
so that's what this code is all about i
will get
event.previous dots results so that will
give me
all the results that i passed down from
the previous function
and then i'm going to create an order so
we will create an order using aws
dynamodb sdk so that's what this
function does so it will pass down the
payload and create an order and then
we will link the books that he purchased
to this order select what this create
book
order function does now there's a
many-to-many relationship between
orders and books so that's why we have
this type exist you know the book order
so this is the third table that handles
this many-to-many relationship
you know when we are defining them in
domain relationship we have this third
table
that handles it so the book coder
it will have two main attributes the
book id
and the old id so when we are creating
an order from
the create order function we will first
create the order
and then get the order id and then we'll
create another record
in the book order table so that will
have
the order id of that order then we'll
create
links for each and every book in that
order so old id book id so if we
purchase three books then
the same old id will be there for three
records but the book ids will be
different
now with this connection we can achieve
two things
so one of the things is a user can see
his previous orders
so we can provide a feature which i
haven't added it anyway in this demo
a user can view his previous orders
because a user can have many orders
right and in the same time
from the admin panel you can look up all
the orders of
all the users or all the orders of a
certain user so that is also possible
now in order to set up these
relationships we use
the connection directive now
the book it has multiple orders so
it will have multiple book coders so
this is the third table that we are
referencing right
so it will have multiple book coders and
there is the connection
in the same time order has multiple
books
so that is of again book code middle
function and when we are resolving it we
are querying these attributes by using
the secondary indexes now in order to
get all the books for an order we use
the by order this secondary index
to do the other way around that means to
get all the orders
for a book we use by book
secondary index right here both indexes
are defined in the
book code type i hope this is clear so
let's move on
so i'll pull up the terminal again it's
waiting for my
command so let me hit enter
then that will start executing this
graphql schema and
create that full blown schema for us
okay it is done
now the next step would be to push all
these resources onto aws so it will
create and provision these resources
but before that we have some
dependencies in the lambda functions
which we need to fill up
and i'll go to amplify backend functions
let's first go to process payment under
the source
index.js as you can see it use aws sdk
as one of the dependencies but this is
provided at the lambda runtime
so it's fine but we need to fill in the
user pool id and the stripe
private key i don't have this one yet
so let's do an amplify push anyways
now the amplify push is going to create
these resources
in aws a user pool with our own category
s3 bucket with our storage category
appsync api with our api category
and the dynamodb together with devsync
as the resolvers
and the two lambda functions again as
part of our api
pipeline resolvers i'll do amplify push
so after this i will get an user pull id
then i'll update this again
yes so all these are yet to create my
two function
st bucket both the user pool and the app
sync api
now i want to generate the code so i can
easily use
my api from front-end i don't have to
write any code
say yes i want it in javascript
in these folders queries mutation
subscription yes i want them
and how deeply it is nested let's use
four because
in future we may add more nested queries
all right so now it is successful and it
took me about three minutes to
complete this whole process now let's
understand the two functions that
process a book code
let me close all these windows now in
source folder
i should find a file called aws
export.js
let me copy this user pool id there
and go to amplify function process
payment
and replace this placeholder with that
then i need a stripe
private key for that you need to create
a stripe account
go to stripe.com and then sign up for
account
and in the dashboard you will see get
your test api keys
so from our react front-end we will use
the public key
to generate a stripe token then that
token will be passed down to our lambda
function
then we will use a secret key to make a
charge for the user
so first i will copy the public key and
then let's first update the front end
for that you go to source and pages
check
out and there's another place folder for
the public key
save it then i'll view the
secret key copy that go to the lambda
function
and here i will paste it by the way you
should use your own
private and public key because i'm going
to remove this account
so payment process dependencies are now
complete
let's go to create order function
dependencies source
even index.js and there i have to
install
guid or uuid so right click open in
terminal
then let me type npmi uuid
now since this function create orders in
the dynamodb
table directly we have to pass the order
table
and the book code table so that will
create the link between boot book
and the order so how to find that
so take another new terminal and then
type
amplify console so that will open your
amplify project in aws automatically
choose the correct region this is it i
click on to that
then here go to in environment and then
i'll click
the prod environment i created then i
see the categories i have added
can go to api and under that i get all
the data sources
the table names so i need the book table
name and the
book order table name so i'll click view
here that that will open up the dynamodb
table
so this is the order table so let me
copy this
order table name replace the placeholder
then i need the book called a table so
this is the book code
table copy
paste it save okay with that i'm going
to run
another amplify push
so this time it will update only these
two functions
as you see update is only for these two
functions everything else is not changed
so it will be much quick now hey one
other additional thing
when you are storing these strings you
know this because this
private key is very sensitive you can
use
ssm or parameter store and then refer
this parameter store variable here
or else you can use the secret manager
as well
so with that we have successfully
configured all our resources on cloud
okay now that we have spent much time on
configuring the application
let's run the app with the current
configuration
clear the screen let's run npm install
to install the dependencies for our
front-end
in the package.json we have bunch of
dependencies to be installed
let me run npm i or npm install
that will install all the dependencies
okay now let's start our application by
running
npm run start
here we go it opens up our application
but we don't have any books
no featured books no books scottish
empty
everything so why don't we create some
books from the admin section go to admin
slash admin
and let's create an admin user
so let's create a normal user first and
we'll
make him an admin i'll use 10 minutes
email to get a temporary email
box
put that email address here fake phone
number
create account let me see if i get an
email right away and this is the
verification id copy that
paste confirm great now we are in the
add new book section
so let's add a book click choose file
let's add this one
paste some description author
let's make it a feature book now before
i submit
let's take a console and inspect it
network
and i'll hit submit
i don't see anything now
so let's go to our project go to our
admin page
so on the pages we have admin so this is
the admin component
so on top we are requiring react
and also use date for keeping some
states and then
we import some amplified dependencies so
one of those dependencies is this create
book mutation when we do amplify push
it's going to create all the mutations
queries and subscription in javascript
for us
and those files are in this graphql
folder you see we have mutation we have
queries
but in my file i am referencing a
mutation
file in api folder which is here so at
the moment it has nothing
queries it is empty why i'm doing that
because
this graphql folder is always being
replaced as and when
i do an update so i want to keep it
constant and have more control over it
so that's why i am referencing a
different directory
but now let's go to mutation in the
graphql folder copy that
and go to this api folder mutation save
it
similarly queries copy this and
queries paste it now my previous data is
anyway
not here so let me add it quickly let's
try submitting again
and i'm getting an error in creating
to-do's so let's observe this error
so i get an error called unauthorized
now as you remember
the creation of books is only allowed
for admin so we sign up a user but he's
not an admin
so let's create him an admin so i'll
take another terminal
let's go to amplify console
click on authentication then i can view
my users in the user pool
click this user pool button pick the
region
so click on my user pool here then i get
number of users one so i'll go to users
so this is our admin user
so now i go to groups and then create a
new group
i call this group admin so it has to
match exactly the
word or the string that we give in our
schema file
admin user groups to create books i
don't have to select a role but
precedence
are set as 0. so the lesser the
precedence more priority is given
so this is basically if i'm part of
multiple groups which group
should be prioritized so then i'll
create the group
go into that then i'll add the user
i'll click the admin user again don't
get confused my group name is also admin
the username is also admin but this
username could be anything
so now let's go back and clear the
screen and try
submitting before that i have to sign
out then only it will take effect
login again okay now i go to the bottom
and click
submit so this time
it should be successful and i don't get
any error the create book is now
successful
so i'll refresh and add another book
because i haven't implemented this
clearing up feature
which i will do in upcoming day so let
me add another file
or book rather
submit it and be successful
so we have two books so i think that
should be enough
so let's go to home i have to do a
refresh
but even though i don't see any books
returned to me
right now i'm not authenticated user
because i signed out but why is it not
showing
so let's inspect the query that triggers
in the home page
so it is basically list book query and i
am getting an error
so i get unauthorized error and if i
further look into this
there's something unauthorized in the
book coders connection
so let's look at that query so i will go
to home
page under pages go to home and i'm
using the context api here
so i have a context for book so the book
context
so so that is there inside
the context folder so right here and
this is the book context
in the book context we are fetching
books and once we fetch the book we set
this featured books in a separate array
and all the books in a separate array
so our components that use this context
can refer
either of it but however in order to get
the books it is using this list books
query so if i go to queries
so that is list books now this all looks
fine except for one thing
that is this orders now an
unauthenticated user
can only look at the books read the
books
these orders attribute or the fields
are coming from a connection with the
older type
or the table but they are not authorized
to be with that's why
it is saying unauthorized this field is
unauthorized but everything else is
authorized for him
so what i will do is i will remove this
and save it and this is one of the
advantage that we can reap
when we have these queries and mutation
outside this automatically
updating folder so that's why i put it
in a separate fold in the first place
so now let's look at it and as you can
see
it is loaded very nice but there's
another problem
you know my images are not loading so
let's go back to our amplify console
and this time let's go to file storage
and here in the file storage
so i will view my bucket in s3 and when
we upload book images so it has
uploaded into a folder called public and
inside that there's another folder
called
images then we have these three images
in order for an unauthenticated user to
weave the books
we have to add the public permission for
this folder
with amplify storage there are three
levels of folders public folder private
and protected
public is for everybody to see but still
again we have to add some permission to
this
since we are using the api key
authentication to request these
resources
so what i will do here is i will go to
permissions
and go to bucket policy and i'll go to
the documentation links right
beneath it and then there's a link
to policy examples and this page if i
scroll little bit down
i'll get grant read-only permission to
anonymous users
so i'll copy this policy come back to my
console s3 and paste it in
here instead of the example bucket i
will replace it with the exact
bucket name is this
paste it out and i don't want the public
access to the entire fold
only to the public folder and inside
that there's a
images folder so you get this
message bucket has public access but
it only has public access to this folder
so i will go back to my wisdomly app and
then
do another refresh we'll see if the
images are now loading
so as predicted now the images loads
next
let's look at how we have actually
connected our front end
to our back end now we already seen some
of these api calls to the backend
but let's look at in page wise so i'll
close all these files
and i will go to the pages folder now
here in the home folder
we display featured products so we use
the context
book context here in the context which
is the book context
and we are passing this featured book
list
to our context thereby from within our
components we can
require it the featured books is nothing
but we get all the books
using fetchbooks
and then we set the featured books to
featured
by filtering them by the featured flag
the boolean value
so it's that simple in the books page we
use
books instead of featured so we'll get
the whole list of books
now both of these pages are public even
the cart page is also public
but when you look at the checkout page
it is not public
you have to log in so that's where we
use this amplify authenticator
and that comes from amplify ui react
library
which got installed when we did npm
install and from there there's a
component amplify authenticator we just
have to wrap it around our
component then you will get that nice
little
login screen so in the same time if i go
to the admin
here also we are wrapping the return
value
or the return jsx using the amplify
authenticator thereby we get the
login screen that's all to it i think
the rest is quite explanatory
when we want to make an api call we get
the api component from
aws amplify and then we'll use
amplify.graphql
then we use this helper function graphql
operation
and we get the corresponding mutation
from our api mutation and then we'll
pass down the
input parameters that's it i mean it's
very easy to make an api call
using amplify because everything is
generated for you
especially these mutations and queries
next
let's create an order and see if it is
properly
processed so in my localhost i'll select
10nx rule and add that to the card let's
increase it
three times i need three of these books
and then i'll go to
startup again one of these the order
total is
63.85 dollars then i'll click
checkout so i have to login in order to
check out
and i only have the admin user so let's
create another user
so i get a new email address and paste
that in
create account let's check there you go
and the verification code paste
confirm
now in the checkout component we have a
place to enter the shipping address
and then the stripe component by the way
let me quickly show you how i linked it
if i go to pages and check out and you
see i'm using stripe elements
from stripe react library for this
element i am pressing the
public key as a attribute and then i
have this
checkout form which is under component
so in this component
i'm using the other elements the card
element
you stripe and those things so it will
properly show
the card element or the place to enter
the card details
which is this one so let's try to add
address and then the card by default it
is four two four two four two
this can be anything and i'll click
submit payment in the order
i get an error it says couldn't find the
module stripe
i think we haven't installed one of
those dependencies let's install that
real quick
amplify backend open it in
terminal stripe let's save it as well
i'll do another amplify push
it's updated so let's try again clear
everything and then
create another payment again there's an
error so this time
i have a different error so if you can
see the hover text it says
this lambda function is not authorized
to perform
cognito admin get user well that is
right because we haven't provided
any permission to this function to call
cognito to get
admin user so let's do that so let's
provide the permission
amplify console
backend environment functions
the process payment i will click view in
lambda
so i can see the role that is currently
attached to this
and then i can add that additional
permission to it and here's the code
and in the permission tab this is the
role that is attached
so i'll click on to this then it will
open that role in identity and access
management
and i'm going to add an inline policy
for that
click inline policy choose the service
cognito and
cognito user pool because we are getting
a user from the cognito user poll
and read i will select the permission
admin get user because that's what we
are doing and which user pool
so let's click on to this and then i
have to add the arn of the user pool
so let's take that i will go to the user
pool which i have open into another step
i will go to general settings then here
i will get the arn
copy that go back to that file click add
arn paste it then click
add review policy
create and that is been attached in the
same time
we have another lambda function that is
create total
and this create total lambda function so
it is connecting to dynamodb
and we have not provided any permission
to interact with dynamodb as well
so let's add that permission as well so
i'll go to amplify console again
and go back to my bookstore backend
environment
again functions select the second
function here
we win lambda so this is the lambda code
permission tab this is the role that is
currently attached to it
so do you see we don't have any
permission for dynamodb
this time instead of an inline policy i
will attach and managed policy
i'll search for dynamo db
so this time i'll add the full access to
dynamodb of course you can add
the granular access only for those two
table
i'll leave it to you but here let the
full
access and i think that should do it
so let's come back and let's try to run
this again
let's see if we get the order successful
message hopefully
submit payment i get another error
well i'll click that once again then it
says the order is successful you know it
takes just a little bit to
propagate that permission that is
understandable so now
my order is successful very nice so how
do we verify whether my order is
successful
we can do it in two ways number one
we can go to our stripe and see if
there's a payment
so in my cart there should be a payment
for 63.85
i'll go to stripe dashboard and payments
tab
and here we go 63.85 so we receive the
payment that means our first lambda
function
charging the user is properly done in
the second lambda function it will do
two things
first it will create the order then it
will create the links
to the books of that order let's go to
amplify
and i'll go to api again then i'll
select view the api the app sync api so
we can run some queries and see exactly
those tables updated let's go to data
sources and then directly look at the
table first so
in the order table we should have an
order record so i'll open it in a new
tab
and here we have the record so the order
is there and 63.85 the total
and the customer email is added so
that's because we set up the identity
field as the email
cancel that and then we'll go to book
quotas there should be
two book coders because we had two
orders
let me quickly show you one and two so
these two books
so there are two records for the same
old id and different two
book ids 79 is the old id 04
and the other one different word id 0 6
but
same old id 04 well with this we can run
some nice queries
so i'll go to appsync console again then
go to queries
how to log in with a user so this time i
will log in
with the admin user how to provide the
client id
so and go to source aws
export.js then we can find the client id
here
copy paste it here then the admin user
login clear everything i'll go back to
my video resources
and example graphql i'll use this query
to list all orders so it's going to list
all orders
and in each and every order it will go
into the books of that order and will
print out
the list of books so let me run that
there you go
so we get the order and the books that
is
included in that order so in the same
time we can filter it by the
customer so let's look at this query so
it's the same query
but with the field attribute this is the
same one but we are adding the filter
let's say this time it's not manoj
fernando see this is
andrew and hit enter
well i don't see the android user and
that's strange so let's go to our
dynamodb table for order and we'll see
if there's a
user column and i don't see it and let's
go to our stripe dashboard and we'll see
if there's a user mention
no you know it is undefined something to
do with the
username let's try to debug it go to
amplify folder
create order index.js and we should get
the username
here but apparently it is not passed
let's go to the previous function where
the username is
passed down to this one so that is
process payment source
index.js well in the handler function
we are trying to access the username
from arguments.input and this is the
error
the username is not inside the
arguments.input
instead it is in the claims so
this is where it is let me
take out the username here because you
don't get the username
and add const username
and paste this one i'll take out the
username part
so it will destructure properly format
it
now it should do it so i take console
and then
do an amplify push again
okay it's updated so let's check that
again
so i will increase the order let's say
180
107.85
submit payment order is successful
let's go to the stripe dashboard to the
payments again
and there we go 180 197.85
and this time we get the user and row
so that means if i go to the query that
i previously ran
and i run it again then i should get
the order now these are the books for
android order
well now we got everything working
except
we haven't host this application so
let's use amplify itself
to host it let's look at the query that
admin can write to get all the orders of
a user
now host this application with amplify
there are multiple
ways one we can link a proper cicd
pipeline
you know with different environment test
qa and production environment
and then you can use custom domains for
these each environment as well
or else we can simply use an s3n cloud
front to host this application as a one
environment
so we'll use the second one in fact
we'll not use cloud front as well just
s3 bucket
so i'll go to my bookstore add a new
category amplify ad hosting
i'll choose the second option cloudfront
ns3
so i'll use the dev environment that is
only s3
hosting bugger name i'll accept the
default index html as our
main page and then i'll do amplify
publish
so i think this is all it it should give
out an url
to an s3 bucket which is configured to
be host and static website
then we can view application on cloud
okay now it is published successfully
so it has open up the
website for me and you can see it is all
here
and it is not on my local machine but on
s3 so i can add
can check out of course i have to log in
and it's all here so this is what i want
to cover in this video
and hey if you are interested about this
content make sure you subscribe to my
channel
for more videos just like these